we're going to begin this hour though
with a story about the power of social
media and a young woman's passion to
keep her father's American Dream alive
more than a million people watch this
video on social media that's restaurant
owner Wang Lee like many eateries he
struggled to stay open in the wake of
the pandemic but as our lead National
correspondent David begno shows us a
very determined daughter helped save the
family business
it all started with this Tick Tock it
makes me so sad to see my parents just
wait for customers to walk through the
door at their Vietnamese restaurant
Jennifer Lee posted that back in January
along with some reviews and it's like my
favorite it's so good of her favorite
dishes from her family's restaurant and
we give a lot of portions too
so good so good in Santa Rosa California
just
[Music]
ice has been open for 20 years but
financial trouble started in 2017 when
the deadly tubs fire then the largest
wildfire in California history
devastated Santa Rosa their building
survived but left the Lee family out of
business for a month then there was the
pandemic their dining room was forced to
close for six months to go food only
Jennifer's father is Wong Lee especially
we cannot afford a higher employee
so hot so we have to hang in Thai and
took me my way and just hanging there
and tried to survive Lee and his wife
cooked the food they serve it too and
their children help when they can
Jennifer a grad student in Southern
California thought maybe my tick tocks
will go viral and that might help the
family business so this is our Yelp
review if you guys can take photos of
your food and upload it it would really
help my parents business so thank you
guys all so much for the support and
love thank you it worked more than a
million people viewed her first video
and you know what happened after that I
was shocked to see how many people were
here almost immediately new customers
were walking through the door packing
into the tiny 50-seat restaurant heck
even the long time customers couldn't
believe it it's a little too crowded for
me at the moment
so much so that Jennifer ended up flying
home to Northern California just so she
could help her parents serve the food
while the power of social media is like
insane okay come with me to Lee's Noodle
House when Erica Altis saw Jennifer's
Tick Tock she activated her own audience
of more than 100 000 people on Instagram
to help but first she took her family to
eat at least so they could try the food
I realized I live less than two miles
from this place and so I decided to call
on my audience because I have a big
local following and ask them if they
would like to contribute to a larger tip
after I'm done with my meal and pay for
my meal and pay for my tip the meal was
so delicious so fresh the bun was
Perfection you've got to go here the
best part though are of these guys the
owners the tip ended up being I ended up
raising two thousand dollars to give to
the family for their restaurant you know
my community did that for for them how
is it being a local being someone who
likes to contribute to the conversation
locally
so watch
the goodness that has come about for
this restaurant from strangers thanks to
social media I know it's just it's
incredible because not only did people
donate near and far to go towards the
tip but people you know came in for
lunch and they're continuing to come
which is so cool to see that there's so
much momentum still behind it and it
wasn't just like one solid week in a
business it's been weeks of business
which is I think you know changed their
entire business from closing and being
able to stay open which is incredible
it's no secret I love the food oh so
your favorite thing's still the pot
stickers I think so but I mean I I would
eat everything Mr Lee served us and
everyone else that day his wife was back
in the kitchen cooking and that's where
I first met them oh hello David nice to
meet you nice with you thank you for
coming
that donation from Altus is going to
help the Lee family start making some
improvements around here to be honest
you that money that's going to help like
fix the AC central air conditioner buy
new ice machine that carry on because my
AMC broke down my center air broke down
so hopefully I use that money to repair
this summer meanwhile if you're ever in
Santa Rosa and you can't get a seat
there's always take out
this takeaway I think it just gives you
kind of a restored faith in humanity
right I think with so much going on in
the world that people want some good
news and we need to get it more into the
mix so I love that you guys are doing
this and you're highlighting this
because it may make people do this in
their own communities and try to support
restaurants in their own communities or
any business in their Community that's
struggling and so I think that's the
takeaway is one small action can go a
far away too bad yeah it's just bringing
so much love and joy to my family
because without a
the people from community
I don't know if I can survive
and to think it all started with a
daughter just trying to give back to her
own family since Jennifer posted that
video Revenue she says is up 30 to 40
percent if you look at the Yelp reviews
online it's good 4.5 Stars nearly 300
views and take it from me who was eating
like a pig on camera that's some tasty
food
we did notice that David uh
we all wanted to be there a couple of
those buns those pot stickers look great
but you know what strikes me I love the
opening picture of of the dad leaning on
the counter looking so sad and the
daughter capturing that because that
does pull at your heartstrings and you
think how can I help these people and in
the food it's good so there's a big
payoff and I love that story power of
social media which we sometimes a lot of
reporting on how bad it can be this is
how it can be used for good and then
what Erica Alta said about you know
doing away the political divisions and
anything that you think is going wrong
in this country there is so much good
happening and this is an example as
always David what to you brought to us
from you so we appreciate that just
wanted to give you all a little feel
good feeling for the morning
I feel good no David you're like What DJ
Khaled says
[Laughter]
for the Soul David we appreciate it